they've been several Saudi explanations
for Jamarcus Shah jees death the latest
is as unconvincing and contradictory as
all the others the idea that more than a
dozen state agents flew to Istanbul on a
state-owned plane and inside a
state-owned diplomatic facility killed a
well-known critic of the Saudi state
without the country's head of state
knowing is preposterous say most experts
that's not how the absolute monarchy
works they say and yet that was a Saudi
prosecutors storyline today meaning five
people could be executed for the
consulate killings in direct
contradiction of previous Saudi accounts
he claimed this was a rogue operation to
abduct the journalist back to Saudi
Arabia that went wrong and led to his
murder
the Turks aren't convinced here today I
personally have to say that I did not
find some of the explanations to be
satisfactory it is said that this
individual was killed because he
resisted being taken back to his country
whereas this murder as we said before
was planned in advanced Saudi foreign
minister Adel al-jubeir though insists
the crown prince knew nothing His Royal
Highness the crown prince has nothing to
do with this issue in fact the national
security advisor in the u.s. said this
this was a rule operation we have a
better sense of what happened this was
individuals exceeding their authority
and going beyond their mandate and these
individuals made a tremendous mistake
and for this mistake they will pay a
price the consensus among many experts
in Western diplomats is Saudi Arabia's
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman ordered
the murder or at least knew about it but
he's simply too important to the West
and too entrenched in power to be openly
blamed by allies instead deputy heads
must roll in this case quite literally
Dominik Waghorn
Sky News